[Musique]
en prenant de la hauteur on mesure
l'étendue de ce qui pourrait bien être
une catastrophe écologique sans
précédent depuis 20 ans la végétation
est dévasté il y a quelques jours encore
se dresser ici une forêt luxuriante
chênes lièges pins parasols châtaignier
ce matin plus de la moitié de cette
réserve naturelle a disparu des arbres
mais aussi des animaux
là on est en train de voir disparaître
peut être potentiellement
deux premières tortues calcinés ont déjà
été retrouvés comme momifiés par les
flammes tout une biodiversité a payé le
lourd tribut de cet incendie la première
végétation qui va arriver va falloir
deux à trois ans pour que on ait
l'impression de végétation qui a
retrouvé en fait une certaine naturalité
après il faudra probablement plus de 15
ans voire même trente ans pour retrouver
ce qu'on a ce qu'on avait avant feux sur
le front des incendies les mauvaises
nouvelles se succèdent
après une accalmie les flammes ont
repris de plus belle
avec le réchauffement climatique des
feux exceptionnels comme celui ci
pourrait devenir plus fréquent y compris
en france
étant donné son intensité sa gravité sa
rapidité de propagation on a affaire
effectivement un phoque est vraiment
différent de ce que auquel on pouvait
être habitués y avait souvent eu je
tairai des feux saisonniers même des
feux très grave dans le passé mais là le
problème c'est que les faudra tendent à
revenir tous les ans et à devenir la
norme sur ces images satellites
des piscines par dizaines utile en été
mais sont elles toutes déclarées pour le
savoir les autorités vont désormais
s'appuyer sur google objectif traquer
les fraudeurs un géant américain qui
travaille pour le fisc français une
nouveauté loin de faire l'unanimité
trouve ça un peu étonnant comme méthode
ça me paraît un peu trop je pense qu'à
peut-être d'autres sujets en ce moment
qui sont un peu plus graves grâce à dieu
et au travail de beaucoup nous avons
maintenant des vaccins pour nous
protéger contre la copie de 19 il nous
donne l'espoir d'en finir avec la
pandémie mais seulement s'ils sont
disponibles pour tous et si nous
travaillons ensemble il ya être vaccinés
avec les vaccins autorisés est un acte
d'amour jean luc est un vacciner de la
première heure depuis quelques semaines
il a vu avec tristesse le dialogue
devenir impossible avec sa fille de 34
ans qui ne souhaite pas se faire
vacciner les seuls arguments que j'ai pu
obtenir ses seins on attend vaccins
sanofi et autres arguments c'est on n'a
pas de recul justement sur les vaccins
aujourd'hui on arrive dans une impasse
sûr que chaque partie prenante voit ses
arguments condamné parce que cadenassée
c'est de vendre toutes nos écoles sur
leurs potes on l'a on est très fier il
ya marqué liberté égalité fraternité
il serait temps de mettre en place le
dernier mot qui s'appelle fraternité moi
c'est la raison pour laquelle j'ai été
me faire vacciner à l'âge de 42 ans
alors qu'ils n'avaient aucun risque
uniquement pas pour aller au resto juste
pour pouvoir être fraternel au même
titre pour le pied la raison pour
laquelle je paye mes impôts et tout le
reste moi c'est mon fils de 21 ans qui a
coupé les ponts avec son père et moi car
nous sommes vaccinés je n'ai plus de
nouvelles depuis avril 2021 ma femme
s'est fait vacciner je les quitter ok
j'ai compris tu soutiens ce gouvernement
corrompu et cette société nauséabonde
voilà c'est ça je suis une social
traître allez hop toi tu dégages de mon
cercle d'amis by
arrêté de me donner des gens sur soyez
sûr tout cela je dis ce col voulons
enseigner et il se trouve que je ne
sentais barrage par aux opinions touchés
voilà c'est tout c'est un endroit encore
c'est bon
ça fait du bien j'ai vu ce petit silence
j'ai pas même tendance de tête quoi
observe quand tu me regardes break ou
quoi chômer regarde
[Musique]
la contrôler
pour la naissance de la nôtre première
fille on avait mis un budget de côté
pour la chambre et marion a
appris ce budget qui est un budget
important on parle de 800 euros pour
s'acheter une paire de chaussures de
marque
oui je fais des constats les ça peut ça
peut dormir dans une caisse à chaussures
quand même donc au début je pensais que
c'était une blague mais en fait pas du
mais non quoi les femmes font l otan
enfonce
méfie commence très jeune elles peuvent
avoir leur premier enfant à 13 ans en
avoir deux ou trois à l'âge de 15 ans
encore et c'est comme ça qu'elles
peuvent avoir lu ton franc à 30 ans
et l'autre raison c'est ce que faire
l'amour est devenu un passe temps
ces femmes n'ont pas de travail donc
elles ont beaucoup de temps pour faire
vous voyez ce que je veux dire mais un
jour thérèse décida de rendre hommage à
son site web préférés jackie et michel
sur un mur de sa maison
le maire en prix tombent rage et une
controverse éclate alors ce qu'ils
exigent a calé face à l'inscription
qu'agent donc pour l'enlever c'est ce
que j'ai fait je pensais qu'on avait
loin de dire ce qu'on voulait en france
bon vous êtes d'accord on est prêt à
faire n'importe quoi pour faire durer un
couple et un mariage au danemark par
exemple marié doit trouver sa chaussette
sinon ce sont ses amis qui s'en
chargeront oui parce que si le marié à
une chaussette trouée il intéressera
donc aucune femme et donc il sera fidèle
à la tradition ça donne une idée de la
femme quand même exactement donc
j'allais enlevés qu'est ce qu'il fallait
faire et je les glisser tout doucement
vers ma voiture
c'est ça la liberté d'expression cette
mère de famille possède une drôle de
ménageries dans sa chambre à coucher est
les peluches en tout je suis rendu à
778 et au moins autant d'objets complète
sa collection débutée il ya 25 ans
coluche figurines pas mal de bugs tous
les jeux vidéo pokémon nager un gaufrier
et derrière j'ai le grille-pain cacho
jalila bon tir doit marcher un peu ce
paravent comment gérez vous et moi je
mange pas vous courez vétérans
conseillons cours léon manche ah c'est
pas une légende de consensus on roule
c'est une passion un peu débordante je
vous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la moitié de son salaire de livreuse de
journaux il passe un sacrifice
totalement choisie et assumée ce cas
évidemment pour avoir ça on ne peut pas
partir en vacances donc c'est soit l'un
soit l'autre voilà bah oui voilà on fait
autre chose mais en sanglotant
couvertures voir tout ça à la fois le
mal de mer non non non c'est pas ça je
voudrais pas trop bouger
souviens toi là de vomi ces centres
droite à la caméra